there's something so soothing so
familiar about clicking on monsters
until they fall over dead Grim Dawn
provides the low-risk high-reward kind
of gameplay isometric action
role-playing games typically deliver
even as an early access purchase on
Steam for $29.99 its development studio
is humbled by Arthur Bruno the lead
systems designer of the well-regarded
click fest Titan Quest making an early
purchase of Grim Dawn difficult to
resist
at very least Grim Dawn has the basics
down it's dark demonic world mixes guns
swords and magic into a greatest hits
compilation of role-playing tropes you
choose the armor and the weapons that
best suit your playstyle and then head
out in search of fame and fortune as is
so often the case with these kinds of
games the banal story is just an excuse
to get you moving but where Grim Dawn
might have made a mark by depicting a
unique world it's perfectly content to
be just another Fantasy Kingdom in a
genre where path of Exile torchlight 2
and even a Camaro were recognizable
on-site Grim Dawn sticks with the dark
fantasy creatures were used to and
depicts a generically attractive land
that doesn't evoke any mood in
particular but make no mistake Grim Dawn
is attractive and it executes the old
formula as best as can be expected with
just enough panache to keep you clicking
the open-ended class system lets you
explore the talent trees of two
different professions of your choice so
if you've ever wanted to be a pistol
wielding creature summoner here's your
chance
further skills are afforded by rare
equipment that grants you even more
abilities and I found myself mixing and
matching skills in ways I didn't
initially intend mix and match character
builds aren't always effective in games
like this but I never felt particularly
challenged at least not until I made my
way to grim Dawn's final extensive
dungeon it's difficult for the developer
of a Diablo s role-playing game to grab
your attention with 29.99 you aren't
just buying an early access game but
also making a statement of trust in its
maker
Grim Dawn comes with a sturdy foundation
and with lots of features coming in the
future like cooperative play and
additional acts the game is likely to be
fleshed out and supported for some time
to come that's just as well considering
you only get about six to eight hours of
adventuring in the current build
question is then whether Grim Dawn can
gain an identity of its own given how
much of what Grim Dawn does is done just
as well elsewhere and with a little bit
more flavor that's not an absolute given